♪
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN GETTING TEST
WITH THE MEDIA IN LYING ABOUT
INFLATION.
THE COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF CLAIMS H
DESERVES NO BLAME WHATSOEVER FO
THE ECONOMY WHILE DENYING HIS
RECKLESS SPENDING LED TO
RECKLESS PRICES.
THE IDEA THAT THE COST INFLATIO
IS BIZARRE, IF IT'S MY FAULT,
WHY IS IT THE OTHER MAJOR
INDUSTRIAL, WHY IS IT THE CASE.
THAT IS HIGHER.
YOU ASK YOURSELF THAT.
I'M NOT BEING THE WISEGUY,
THAT'S THE END OF THE QUOTE TO
PETER DUCEY PRESSING THE WHITE
HOUSE ON THAT WHOPPER OF A CLAIM
.
>> HE SAYS THAT INFLATION IS
WORSE EVERYWHERE, BUT HERE,
THAT'S NOT TRUE.
THE WORST IS U.S. WORSE
INFLATION THAN JAPAN, ITALY,
SAUDI ARABIA,.
>> I THINK THAT WHAT WE ARE
SEEING IS THAT WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT INFLATION, IT IS A GLOBAL
THING RIGHT IT IS NOT JUST ABOU
THE UNITED STATES, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT EVERYONE IS
FEELING BECAUSE OF COMING OUTS
OF A ONCE-IN-A-LIFETIME PANDEMIC
, BECAUSE OF THAT WAR
THAT RUSSIA HAS STARTED IN
UKRAINE.
>> AND AFTER BLABBING AWAY TO
THE AP, IT SEEMS LIKE THOSE
CLOSE TO THE PRESIDENT DIDN'T
WANT HIM TO DO ANYMORE TALKING.
>> THE WHITE HOUSE CONSIDERING
TRYING TO BUY VOTERS OFF BY
SENDING AMERICANS GAS REBATE
CARDS TO OFFSET THE SURGE IN
PRICES.
THERE ARE SO MANY PLACES I CAN
START, BUT I'M NOT STARTING WIT
YOU, GREG, BECAUSE YOU PUT YOUR
HAND UP ON THE TELEPROMPTER.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS SPECIFICALLY
IF IT IS MY FAULT, WHY ISN'T IT
THE CASE IN EVERY MAJOR
INDUSTRIAL PLACE AND THE NATION
THAT INFLATION IS HIGHER.
THEY CAN MAKE EVERY EXCUSE THEY
WANT, BUT HE LIED.
HE LIED, OR HE'S INCOMPETENT,
WHICH IS IT?
>> THAT MOST SURPRISING THING I
SHE DIDN'T MAKE A GOOD EXCUSE.
SHE COULD HAVE FAILED SOME SMAL
GROUP OF COUNTRIES AND SAY, BUT
WE ARE BETTER THAN THEY ARE.
SO MAYBE, THERE IS ANOTHER JOB
OFFER FOR YOU.
>> ARE YOU TRAINED TO GET RID O
ME.
CONGRESSMAN JASON SMITH.
HE GETS HER TO ADMIT THAT THERE
IS TO REDUCE DEFICITS.
AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT HOW THEY
REDUCE THAT IS LAUGHABLE.
IT REDUCING DEFICIT REDUCES
INFLATION, THEN IT DOESN'T TAKE
A VERY PART ART PERSON TO SAY
THAT INCREASING INCREASES
INFLATION.
I WISH YOU WOULD DRIVEN THAT
POINT HOME.
THEN JOE BIDEN DOES HAVE TO
ACCEPT RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE
MAJORITY.
>> ANY LEADER WORTH HIS OR HOLD
SALT WOULD EMPATHIZE AND OFFER
SOLUTION.
THIS PRESIDENT IS INCAPABLE AS
MUCH AS PEOPLE THOUGHT HE
EMPATHIZED ABOUT OBIT, HE IS
INCAPABLE OF ACCEPTING THE FACT
THAT HE IS RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT
HAS HAPPENED INTO THIS ECONOMY
AND HE'S DOING NOTHING AS HE
CONTINUES TO TRASH FOSSIL FUELS.
>> THIS IS A GLOBAL PROBLEM, BU
HE IS THE PRESIDENT OF ONE
COUNTRY.
YOU CAN'T JUST LEAVE IT THAT.
HE SAID EVERY OTHER MAJOR
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD.
>> I THINK HE MIGHT'VE MISSED O
THAT.
>> HE LIED.
>> IN THE WHOLE WORLD.
9.8 PERCENT.
NETHERLANDS,.
>> SO WHAT?
SO WHAT?
>> THAT IS ALIVE.
ADMITTED.
>> IF YOU THINK THAT LIED TO ME
HAS MALICIOUS INTENT THE
PRESIDENT SHOULD NOT HAVE SAID
THAT.
HE SHOULD SAY WE ARE FACING A
GLOBAL CHALLENGE.
WE ARE RUNNING BASICALLY IN THE
BACK OF THE PACKER.
>> THE ECONOMIC SITUATION THEY
ARE IN.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD SAY
THEY HAVE RESPONSIBILITY FOR ITS
.
GIG.
>> IT'S STRANGE TO ME.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THINGS THAT HE DID AND DID
UP PUSHING IT IN THIS DIRECTION.
AND THEY SAID WE SPENT SO MUCH.
GENITIVE SAID SHE WANTED THE
AMERICAN RESCUE ACT, THEN IT
ENDED UP BEING.
THAT IS A FINE ARGUMENT TO MAKE
TWO ADULTS IN THIS COUNTRY WHO
UNDERSTAND GENERALLY SPEAKING
THAT WE ARE PART OF A GLOBALIZE
ECONOMY.
THAT WE NEEDED TO BAIL OUT TO
SOME DEGREES, BUT PERHAPS IT
WENT TOO SO FAR.
THINK THE CHANGING COURSE AND
SHOWING THAT EMPATHY FROM THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL WOULD BENEFIT HIM
.
HIS BACK IS UP AGAINST THE LAW.
AND HE DOESN'T WANT TO DO A.
HE IS SO TONE DEAF.
ON CLIMATE CHANGE WHERE PEOPLE
CAN'T AFFORD GAS TO DRIVE TO
WORK.
>> THAT IS THE BIGGER STORY.
I AM KIND OF WITH JESSICA ON
THIS.
ACCUSING POLITICIANS OF LYING I
LIKE ACCUSING BIRDS OF CHIRPING.
IT'S JUST IN THEIR DNA.
WHEN WE DO WELL, THEY DO WELL,
WHEN WE DO POORLY, THEY DO
POORLY.
OUR HIGH INFLATION IS KIND OF
RESPONSIBLE FOR A LOT OF OTHER
HIGH INFLATION'S.
I'M NOT SAYING THAT AS A PHD IN
ECONOMICS.
SO BLAME GAME.
THE WHITE HOUSE HAS THE
HIERARCHY OF NEEDS BACKWARDS.
LAW AND ORDER ON THE STREET.
IN THE HIERARCHY OF NEEDS, NOT
SOLAR PANELS, NOT CRICKET
RECIPES, NOT DRAG SHOWS FOR KIDS
, THOSE ARE ALL THE FUN
THINGS YOU CAN HAVE WITH
EVERYTHING ELSE IS GREAT.
IN THE HIERARCHY OF NEEDS, YOU
HAVE TO HAVE THE FOOL, AND THE
LAW AND ORDER.
A LOT OF THESE YOUNG PEOPLE AND
THE WHITE HOUSE, THEY DON'T KNO
HOW TO SOLVE ACTUAL PROBLEMS.
IF YOU NEED AN INSTAGRAM PHOTO
DURING A SPECIAL MONTH OR A
SPECIAL DAY, AND YOU SAY YOU
KNOW WHAT TO SAY, THAT THEY CAN
DO.
THEY CAN ASAP, BUT IF YOU TALK
ABOUT GAS PRICES OR BABY FORMULA
, IF YOU TALK ABOUT WAR,
IF YOU TALK ABOUT THESE BIGGER
ISSUES, THEY JUST APPOINTED
KAMALA HARRIS TO RUN ANOTHER
ANTI- ONLINE HARASSMENT BOARD
AND SAID THAT DOES NOTHING TO
HELP ANYBODY.
I LIKE YOUR JACKET IT'S VERY
GARBLED ROLE.
SOMEONE WHO IS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE GREATEST COUNTRY ON EARTH
HAS THE OBLIGATION TO BE
TRUTHFUL TO PEOPLE WHO VOTED FO
HIM.
SO WHEN HE COMES OUT AND SAYS
DON'T BLAME ME, BLAME FOOD.
AND HE SAYS, INFLATION IS WORSE
EVERYWHERE, BUT HERE.
HE SAYS THAT HE INHERITED A BAD
ECONOMY.
DID HE INHERIT A BAD ECONOMY?
>> HE INHERITED AN ECONOMY
RECOVERING FROM COVID, AND HE
BRAGGED ABOUT JOB CREATION.
WE ARE STILL SHORT.
ROUGHLY ABOUT 800,000 JOBS,
WE'RE NOT EVEN BACK TO THE
EMPLOYMENT WE HAD BEFORE THE
COVID LOCKDOWN.
THEY SHOULD COME OUT AND SAY I
WILL VETO ANYTHING THAT WILL
INCREASE GOVERNMENT SPENDING FO
THE FORESEEABLE FUTURE.
THE MORATORIUM ON STUDENT LOAN
PAYMENTS, THAT MONEY IS GOING
TOO RICH KIDS.
THEY END UP EXTENDING IT SO THE
COULD DO AT LEAST THAT.
THEY'RE TAKING IT ONE STEP
FURTHER.
THIS IS THE LEVEL OF IDIOCY THA
WE ARE TALKING ABOUT FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
THEY ARE TALKING ABOUT GAS
REBATES.
ANYBODY IN THAT WHITE HOUSE
KNOWS THIS FROM ECON 101 THAT
THEY TOOK IN UNDERGRADUATE
SCHOOL, THE DUMBEST THING YOU
CAN DO WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
FIGHT INFLATION, DO NOT GIVE
MONEY OUT TO BUY COMMODITY THAT
IS IN LIMITED SUPPLY THAT YOU
ALREADY HAVE EXCESS DEMAND.
THEY ARE JEN HANDING MONEY TO
BOOST DEMAND WHEN SUPPLIES ARE
TIGHT.
THAT IS BEYOND.
THEY CONTINUED TO DO THIS.
THEY WILL PROBABLY ALREADY BE IN
, IT'S GOING TO TAKE A DEEP
RECESSION TO FIX THIS INFLATION.
WHEN HE COULD HAVE FIRED THEM
AND THEY DIDN'T.
>> I UNDERSTAND THE ECONOMY ANY
BETTER, BUT YOU JUST EXPANDED M
VOCABULARY BY ABOUT TWO WORDS.
>> I